so we talk about it every holiday season
as we decorate turn on the fireplace
maybe the heater
the risk of fire goes up this time of
year bianca holman is live with tips to
keep your family
safe and everything where it should be
hey bianca
hey good morning alex you know this year
has been very stressful so
a lot of people are holding on to family
traditions like decorating a christmas
tree
and while we've got a fake one here in
the station a lot of people are
into getting real trees this year so
many people are getting real trees
they're getting them
earlier that means the real tree is
going to be in the home a longer than
normal
now there are some extra precautions
that you need to take if you have a real
treat we've got dryness of the desert
air here and so it's important to water
the tree
every day once in the morning and again
in the evening the reservoir at the base
should never be dry a sap seal can form
at the bottom of the trunk within 10
minutes
a tree fire can be started by electric
lighting so those small lights even
though they're tiny they can provide
enough heat to cause a fire if you
decide to have
a christmas tree a live christmas tree
in your house
it's the same as saying i want to have a
pet
and if you have a pet you have to pay
attention to it every day you have to
feed it
you have to water it you have to take
care of it and that's the same
responsibility if you're going to have a
live christmas tree
once you get the tree home before you
put it in the holder you're supposed to
cut off about an inch from the bottom so
it can absorb the water
water the tree twice a day perform a
freshness test
daily if the needles fall off of the
tree in excess that means
the tree is dead inspect any frayed or
broken light
turn off the lights when you go to bed
or leave the house and keep any heat
source away from
the tree and again if a tree catches
fire it can
fill the room within a minute so it's
very important again to take heed to
many of these suggestions that we talk
about every year but coming up we're
going to share more
about some winter holiday fire safety
tips reporting live bianca holman
8 news now yeah that's